Now, I want you to actually
build the Turing machine.
The goal is to right shift the input,
and
place a dollar sign symbol
in front of it, and accept.
Unlike our previous examples, accept
versus reject isn't important here.
This is more like a subroutine
within a larger Turing machine
that you might want to build.
Though you could think about it as a
Turing machine that computes a function
from all strings over the input alphabet
to a string over the tape
alphabet if you like.
I'll illustrate my recommended
strategy with the example of shifting
the string 01.
First, we move the head to
the end of the tape and
replace the symbol with a blank.
Then, we write this symbol
one past where it was before.
Then we rewind two steps and repeat.
First, erasing the symbol, and then
writing it one past where it was before,
like so.
Then we rewind two steps.
And in rewinding, we detect that we
have reached the beginning of the tape
because we end up finding
the blank symbol here.
We try to rewind once, and then we try
to rewind again, that would put us off
the end of the tape, but we end up
staying here at this location instead.
So we end up reading a blank symbol,
and that tells us that we're finished.
And so we can just write
the dollar symbol, and we're done.